[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID KWONG: Hi.
Hello, Google.
Thank you for having me back.
It's so great to be here.
My name is David Kwong.
I am a magician.
I'm also a puzzler.
I write a lot of crosswords
for "The New York Times."
I've basically taken the
world's nerdiest hobbies
and combined them
right into one career.
[LAUGHTER]
But that's because I think
magic tricks are puzzles
I think they are ways
of challenging your mind
and testing you to figure out
the solution, which is why I
thought I'd start off with this,
the Rubik's Cube, which I think
is now 42 or 43 years old.
I'm sure there are tons
of cubers here at Google.
I kind of solve them
like a magician.
You could see there's
a pretty good mix.
I can just toss this up like
that I can solve the Cube.
Don't worry.
It'll get better.
[APPLAUSE]
I am here to talk about
my new book and the way
a magician thinks.
And this is a very
exciting for me.
I've really just given
one presentation in LA.
And this is my first coming
out party with "Spellbound."
A little bit about me--
I am part of a small group
of practitioners of magicians
that do not pretend in any way
whatsoever to have superpowers.
I acknowledge right up
front that it's all science.
It is all planning
and preparation
and the art of misdirection and
understanding human behavior.
And most magicians
are not that way.
But there are some
great examples
of people that have
had this approach are
like Penn and Teller, who
for decades have acknowledged
that it's all trickery and some
of the great sleight of hand
artists as well.
Which is why I wrote
this book, "The Seven
Principles of Illusion"
Don't call them
magic police on me.
These are just principles,
fundamental principles.
I've tried very hard not
to ruin anyone's magic show
with this book.
I do want to take you through
a couple of the principles.
And it starts with a
story out of Hollywood.
I live in Los Angeles.
And my good friend, Edgar
Wright, the film director--
"Shaun of the Dead," "Hot Fuzz,"
"Scott Pilgrim vs. The World"--
can throw those
up on the screen.
He asked me to come
over to his house
and teach him how
a magician thinks.
And Edgar, as you can
imagine, is really
into con games and deception.
And he has a movie
that's coming out
next month called
"Baby Driver," which
is about a getaway
driver for heists.
So I was not surprised when
he called me up and asked
me to come over and teach him
how a magician and a con man
thinks.
The afternoon did not
get off to a great start.
I showed up about
15 minutes late.
I was with my
friend, Blake Vogt,
who's a fantastic magician
and trick creator.
And we couldn't find the house.
And we were
apologizing profusely.
But everything was fine
once we started performing
tricks in the living room.
Edgar was happy.
We were happy.
But then we finished.
And Edgar said, show
me your best trick.
And we're like, Edgar, we
just-- we just showed--
we just did our coolest stuff.
But OK.
We have an idea.
Do you have a driveway?
Do you have an outdoor
space that we can go to?
And Edgar said, well,
I have a backyard.
Let's go to the
backyard instead.
So we went out through the
kitchen to the veranda.
And we stood in this
lovely backyard.
And I said to Edgar,
name any playing card--
absolute free choice.
He said five of hearts.
And then we said, point
anywhere you want in the yard.
And he pointed at a
bush at about 2 o'clock
from where we were standing.
And I said, I want you
to go over to that bush
and get down in the dirt at the
mulch at the base of that bush
and dig.
And that's what he did.
And he found a folded
up playing card.
And it was the five hearts.
Edgar lost his shit.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, normally I keep the
method behind a secret
like this to myself.
I do not share.
I do not reveal the secrets.
But because Edgar had asked
me to come over and teach him
how a magician thinks, Blake
and I pulled out an iPad
and we played him
this video here.
This is Blake burying 52 playing
cards in Edgar's backyard
three hours before the meeting.
And we memorized exactly
where they were going.
Now this is how magic works.
It's not smoke and mirrors.
It's not dancing ladies.
It's forethought.
It's anticipation.
It's planning.
And as a puzzler
and a magician, I
operate in that intersection
between preparation
and misdirection.
Now, what this involved
was a principle called
"the illusion of free choice."
And here's what
that principle is.
This is one of the meatier
chapters of my book,
the Illusion of Free Choice.
It basically states that if you
can get your audience believing
that they are dictating
how a trick goes,
they will buy into
the illusion more.
Blake and I did
not make this up.
Think about this.
When was the last time
that you had a project
that you were trying to
get your boss to approve
and in order to
get your approval,
you convinced her it was
her idea to begin with.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
That's the illusion
of free choice.
Or if you're in a sales
meeting, if you're
trying to sell your
product, you would probably
have more success if
you're able to convince
the person on the
other side of the table
that it's their idea rather
than strong arming them
with a hard sell.
Now, I want to talk a little bit
about the social science of how
this works, of why the illusion
of free choice and choice
itself is so effective.
And it involves a
experiment in the year 2000
by two French scientists,
Nicolas Gueguen
and Alexandre Pascual.
Those are the names of
the two French scientists.
And it involved a
theory called "you
are free to accept or refuse."
So here's the experiment
that they did.
They took a young man and they
had him go into a bus station
and ask to one group
of people, may I
please have change for the bus?
And he was given a
certain amount of money.
And then that young man
went into the bus station
and asked another
group of people,
may I please have
change for the bus?
But you are free to
accept or refuse.
Basically, reminding
people of their free will,
which is so, so important to us.
We, as human beings,
are wired to want to be
able to choose things freely.
And the results were the first
group, 5% of the people--
I'm sorry.
10% of the people gave
him money for the bus.
And then the second group that
he reminded of their free will,
47.5% of the people gave--
a nearly 5% increase.
And what's more, is the
people that gave money--
because they were
reminded of their free
will-- also gave more money.
The denomination was higher.
So when you are reminded
of your free will,
you are more compliant and more
cooperative and more obliging.
And magicians know this.
Now there is something else
called the "choice-supportive
bias," which means that
when you choose something,
when you discover something,
when you have your own idea,
you will defend to
that idea to the death.
You will defend it even
in the face of data
that says that you're wrong.
You hold on to your
own ideas deeply.
And magicians know this as well.
And we take advantage
of this as well.
We have something
that we like to do,
which is called
a "leave behind,"
a "leave behind," which is--
well, let me give
you an example that.
It's as if I were doing the
magic coloring book, which
is something you probably
saw at a kids show
when you were younger.
The magic coloring book
is you flip through it,
and it's blank.
And then you flip
through it again,
and there are black
lined drawings.
And then you flip
through it again,
and those drawings
are now colored.
And it's cut like
a fashion magazine.
There are different ways that
you can flip through the book.
I think it's OK that I'm
spoiling the magic coloring
book.
But then after the show when
you're the magician, after you
leave, you, by accident, leave
behind an all-blank version
of the magic coloring
book that you can also
buy for $5 at hocuspocus.com.
It's a great investment.
And when you discover
that yourself when--
or maybe, I can't
tell you how many--
I've done a trick with an
object that's not quite fair.
And then I will leave a
normal object in the trash
can on the way out.
I can't tell you how many
people will go like, hmm.
I'm going to go check that out
because I'm curious and clever.
And when you discover that,
when you take your own freewill
and you discover
that, the illusion
becomes absolutely bulletproof.
So there's a wonderful
example from history
of this being effective.
And it's World War II.
It's April 30, 1943.
And a body is found
floating in the Atlantic
off the coast of Huelva, Spain--
found by a Spanish fisherman.
The body is in military khakis
kept afloat by a life jacket.
And chained to the dead man's
wrist was a locked briefcase.
Now an inspection
of the man's wallet
revealed that his name was Major
William Martin of the British
Navy.
Major Willie Martin, however,
was just an illusion.
He was conjured by a hush-part
of the British Secret Service.
I forget the name
of the actual--
it's like M-17 or
something like that, M-17.
But it was part of the
British Secret Service.
And they went through a
great number of details
to buttress this
illusion that became
known as Operation Mincemeat.
That's what it was called.
Have you heard of that
before, Operation Mincemeat?
Here's what they did.
I'll show you.
This is a picture
of the actual body
that was found in the water.
They took a cadaver.
And put it in military garb.
They took out an
obituary, a death notice
in the evening paper.
And they also had in his wallet
a picture of his girlfriend.
So all these details to
bolster this illusion.
What the Allies were
banking on was that Spain--
which was technically
neutral but seemed
to have formed a slight
alliance with the Germans--
they were banking
that the Spanish would
give the briefcase over
to the Germans secretly
and that they would open the
contents of that briefcase
without anybody knowing.
And inside was disinformation--
disinformation that said
where the Allies were going
to invade from North Africa.
They were perched
in North Africa.
They were gonna invade
across the Mediterranean.
But the Germans
didn't know whether it
was going to be Greece or
Sardinia or the Balkans
or Sicily.
But the disinformation
conveyed that it
was Greece and
Sardinia, which is
where the Germans
concentrated their defenses.
And that allowed the Allies
to invade Sicily instead,
which was undefended.
Operation Mincemeat.
The Allies were what
many sociologists
call a "choice architect."
They design the
choice environment
in which decisions are made.
Cass Sunstein and Richard
Thaler in their book,
"Nudge," really define
this quite well.
So nudging is the
idea for a leader
that you know what
decisions have
to be made for your employees.
But you allow them
to arrive freely
at the best decision themselves.
That's nudging.
Probably the best
way to describe it
is you take the healthy
food in the cafeteria
and you put that at a eye level.
I wonder if Google should take
advantage of this strategy.
Do they?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAVID KWONG: That's great.
So they nudge you here.
But everybody knows where
the pizza is, right?
You had pizza today.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's see.
A choice architect
will design ways
to help people make choices
that they themselves think
are better-- choice architect.
Dwight D. Eisenhower has
a great quote that I love.
And I'll put that up
on the screen, which
is "Leadership is the
art of getting people
to want what must be done,"
Dwight D. Eisenhower.
Now, here's a here's a cool
trick that you can try at home,
how you can be a
choice architect
and alter the
choice environment.
So if you have somebody choose
a playing card-- pick a card,
any card--
let's say it's the
queen of hearts.
And you figure out what it is.
We can talk afterward
about a variety of ways
that you can figure out what
the card is and shuffle it
and control it.
But the reveal should
be the following.
You're going to layout four
cards for your audience.
You're going to put one
card in front of them.
The next card will be the chosen
card, the queen of hearts,
then a third card, and
then a fourth card.
And you're going to say
to your audience member,
choose any card.
And most of the
time, they're going
to go for the queen of hearts.
Why?
Because the first card is
too obvious of a choice.
And the third card
and the fourth card
you've placed just far
enough away on the table
that they have to uncomfortably
get up to touch the cards.
So they'll go for
the second one there.
That's being a choice architect.
Now, you might be wondering
is illusion inherently
deceptive and manipulative?
Well, I am trying to
do something different
with this book.
I believe that illusion,
there is a more positive way
that you can command your
life, and be in control,
and be one, two, three steps
ahead of everybody else.
So just think about
this the next time
you are in a negotiation.
Think about how you can
be a choice architect
and empower the person on
the other side of the table
so that they can make decisions
that are good for themselves,
and good for both of
you, and everybody wins.
Now I want to talk
a little bit more
about the backyard card
trick with Edgar Wright.
Because there were
some ways that we
were able to enhance
that illusion with what
I like to call the
"illusion of spontaneity."
I mentioned that we showed up
three hours before the meeting
to bury cards.
But we were able to sell
the illusion of spontaneity
by showing up for the meeting
15 minutes late on purpose
and saying, sorry.
We couldn't find the house.
We've never been here before.
We're sorry that we're late.
And then we were in his
living room doing tricks.
And we waited for him to
ask us to do one more trick.
We did not offer to
do a final trick.
We waited for him.
It was his idea to see one more.
And then I suggested, let's
go out to the driveway
to do a trick outside.
And I let him upgrade us
to his lovely backyard.
Now of course, if he had
agreed to the driveway,
we would have
pivoted and suggested
the backyard ourselves.
But we didn't need to.
We put everything in his hands.
Now, once we were
in the backyard,
you're probably wondering, how
did we get him to point right
where the five hearts was?
And I'm not going to tell you.
No.
We used a lot of
suggestion and influence
to get him to do that.
But I will say that the
important technique that we use
is that we were able to be in
control of the narrative, which
is another big thing in magic,
which is controlling the story.
And just after the
trick, we started
to reinforce right away, you
could have pointed anywhere
you wanted.
And every time I run into
him at a cocktail party
or at a friend's party
and the story comes up,
hey, remember that trick
we did in your backyard?
You could've pointed
anywhere you wanted.
You pointed right
where the card was.
And I'm always, always
still working on this trick
and improving this trick.
Magicians can manipulate
your memory of what happened.
So I'm done with this.
We can take that down.
I'm going to demonstrate
some tricks for you.
I didn't sneak in here yesterday
and bury 52 playing cards.
But I can.
Let's have a little fun
with the playing cards.
Where did I put that?
I had an open one.
Oh, no?
Am I crazy?
OK.
We'll open a new pack.
Oh, no.
Here we go.
OK.
So instead of one
card, let's try
for a number of playing cards.
And we'll have a number
of playing cards selected.
Actually, you know what?
Take that back.
Let's start with one card.
Let's start with
one signed card.
I'll show you how a magician
can control a single playing
card in the deck.
So I'm going to come right here.
I'm going to come to you, sir.
I'm gonna have you
choose any card you like.
Oh, the top card.
He's that guy.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
That's quite all right.
You are going to sign it so
it's the only card like that.
How do you know I didn't
want you to take that card?
It's like-- no, not on the back.
The back is too
easy for me to find.
Right there on the face.
It's OK if I see it.
It's fine because
you are now making
it a unique card, the only
card with your signature.
Thank you for your help.
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: Matthew.
DAVID KWONG: Matthew?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID KWONG: Great.
Thank you so much.
OK.
So we have Matthew's
six of clubs.
This is how a magician
can track a single playing
card in the deck.
So these are called overhand
shuffle, as you know,
overhand shuffles.
This is a-- it's a
bit of a racist term.
It's called the Hindu shuffle.
And that's because that's how
many people shuffle in Asia.
It's a 19th century term,
or maybe even earlier.
My father from Hong
Kong shuffles this way.
So I'm allowed to
make that joke.
I think we still call
it the Hindu shuffle.
These are, of course, overhand--
I mean riffle shuffles.
Everyone can shuffle
this way, right?
And we have what's called
a faro shuffle, F-A-R-O,
which is an old French
card game, F-A-R-O.
And that's when you split
the cards in half like this.
And they spring together
in such a fashion.
F-A-R-O.
So Matthew, you
chose a playing card.
You chose the six of clubs.
And my goal here is to control
it to the top of the pack.
With a little snap my
fingers, I should be able
get one card, the six
of clubs, to come back
to the top of the pack, right?
Now, this is where it gets
a little more complicated.
I'll take the six of clubs.
I'll place it about
halfway down, push it in,
and if I stopped my fingers,
I should be able to get one--
oh-- one card to come back
to the top of the pack.
All right.
Let's try this again.
I'll give it a few cuts.
And the six of clubs--
Oh yeah.
That's a good one.
The six of clubs-- as
I'll snap my fingers,
I should be able to get
that card to come right up
back to the top of the pack.
I'll give you a sporting
chance to follow the six
clubs this time.
I'm going to take the six.
And I'm going to
leave it sticking off
the top of the pack.
So now, if I cut it down to
the bottom without touching it.
And now it has to rise up
through about 50 other cards
to get to the top.
Now, I promise you it has
not gone to the top yet.
That's the seven of diamonds.
I'm going to take the
seven of diamonds.
I'm going to push in
your card like this.
It's going to rise to the top
and take the place of the seven
of diamonds on the top and then
hop over here to my right hand.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Let's try this.
I'm going to give you a little
demonstration of misdirection--
misdirection--
misdirection.
Let's see.
I'm gonna make this fair here.
Can I show you this?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Anita.
DAVID KWONG: Anita.
So you see the six of clubs.
I'm going to let you see it
til the last second because I
know it's been confusing
with the face down.
So I'm going to let
you see it like that.
And you're going to help me.
We're going to
push into the fan.
So would you take it
and push it flush?
Like knock it right in.
Yeah, good.
[LAUGHTER]
[SHUFFLING CARDS]
Here ya go.
AUDIENCE: Hm?
Ah!
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID KWONG: All right.
Everyone give her a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
That was not fair.
But thank you for being
a good sport there.
Yeah, thank you
for humiliating me
in front of these people, David.
The six of clubs--
six of clubs-- I should be able
to get that back to the top.
I'll let you watch it face up
into the middle of the pack.
I'm going to put it actually
a little closer to the bottom.
I'll leave it face up
this time, face up,
as I put some other
cards on top it.
I will take the second card,
which is the three of clubs.
I'll cover it for just a
moment and snap my fingers just
like that.
And it should change the six.
Did I get you on that one?
Yeah, that's good.
Watch that six of clubs one
more time about 3/4 of the way
down, just like that.
We should be able
to get one card.
Oh, I forgot to snap.
You have to snap
or it doesn't work.
When you snap, then it
turns into the six of clubs.
[LAUGHTER]
Now you're probably
wondering how this works.
What if I told you I had more
than one six of clubs with--
Matthew, with your
signature on it?
What if I told you that I
managed to replicate your card?
And let me show you what I mean.
Look.
We have there's one there.
That's one two, three,
four, five, six.
Is anyone buying this?
Maybe not.
[LAUGHTER]
I showed you six cards
with your signature on it.
But here's the strange thing.
There's only one card
that's been in this box
the entire time.
And if you look in here, you
get one card out of there.
That's a six of clubs.
That's for you to hold on to.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Now--
[APPLAUSE]
Let's make it a
little more difficult
by having a number
of cards selected.
And I'll show you I can
track multiple cards.
And this is called a
multiple selection routine,
which was first
done by Professor
Hoffman in the 19th century.
He's one of the great
card manipulators.
So let's do this.
I'm going to have a number
of people choose cards.
Would you just take one out?
And you may share it with
the people around you.
You may hold it up, so
more than one person--
would you take one for me?
Yeah, great.
That way, everyone's
invested in this trick.
Take a look. take a look.
Would you take a
card for me, please?
Yeah.
I want you to take a
card and hold it up
so all the people behind you
can-- you would like one?
AUDIENCE: I would.
DAVID KWONG: Yes.
OK.
I will give you one.
Oh!
I though you were
going for the top card.
I thought you were gonna
compete with Matthew.
You've got it?
You're happy with that one?
AUDIENCE: Yup.
DAVID KWONG: OK, cool.
Would you take one for me?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah right.
AUDIENCE: That one.
DAVID KWONG: Great,
great, great.
Will you take one?
All right.
Cool.
Wanna take a card?
Excellent.
Share it with the
people around you.
So a number of cards selected.
Good?
OK.
I'm gonna take them
back one at the time.
Thank you.
Take a look.
Everyone take a look.
Remember your card.
Good.
All right.
Excellent.
Now I'm gonna make it a
little more difficult.
I'm mixing these up.
And then I will complicate
them even further
by shuffling in
some other cards.
Now if you chose a card, you
have one job and one job only.
And that is to
remember your card.
Are we good?
These guys are whispering
already because they--
did forget it already?
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
I'm going to take this mix of
cards that I first shuffled up.
And then I shuffled in
some other cards as well.
And I'm going to very
cleanly, very fairly
toss them into the pack.
And you can see, I'm not
marking where they're going.
I'm not crimping the
corners that gamblers do.
I'm putting some at the
top, some in the middle,
some of the bottom.
I'm no taking a pencil and
marking a dot on the corner.
This is truly, as magicians
call it, "a mess" of cards.
And let me square this up.
And I'll stay honest with a good
old-fashioned American riffle
shuffle here, just like this.
OK.
So here's how this
is going to work.
I'll ask you what
card that you chose.
And tell me what it is.
I'll try to locate it
in the pack of cards.
Does that sound fair?
So I'm gonna start with you.
I'll try to do it in order.
What card did you choose?
AUDIENCE: Five of diamonds.
DAVID KWONG: The?
DAVID KWONG: The
five of diamonds.
Cool.
Five of diamonds should
be about halfway down.
I can cut-- this is
kind of a table cut--
one card on the middle should
be the five of diamonds.
This is five of diamonds?
Yeah?
Cool All right.
So far, so good.
Who else did I give a card to?
Did I give you one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: What did you have?
AUDIENCE: Six of hearts.
DAVID KWONG: Six of hearts.
OK.
I'll find the six hearts
using a few swivel cuts.
The swivel cut was made
famous by Nate Leipzig.
Nate Leipzig was known
for his swivel cuts.
And I'll swivel right
out of the middle
and get one card there,
which is the six of hearts.
So that's good.
So far, so good.
Who else did I give a card to?
What did you have?
AUDIENCE: I had the
jack of diamonds.
DAVID KWONG: Jack of diamonds.
OK.
Well, I'm going to take
the five of diamonds
and the six of hearts.
And together, they're
going to go looking
for the jack of diamonds.
So let's see what they find.
The six and the five
should get one card
right there in between them.
And that should be
the jack of diamonds.
And it is the jack of diamonds,
which is good news for me.
And what did you have?
AUDIENCE: Jack of hearts.
DAVID KWONG: Jack of hearts.
And did you have one?
Did you have one?
AUDIENCE: I had
the king of hearts.
DAVID KWONG: Jack of
hearts, king of hearts.
OK.
That's a good pair
to get together.
We'll find the jack of hearts
and the king of hearts--
two cards at once.
Now this is something
that was invented
by Johan Nepomuk Hofzinser, who
is a great Viennese magician.
Yes, that's his real name.
He's the father of
modern card magic.
Johan Nepomuk Hofzinser, 19th
century Viennese magician.
And he would find two cards
at once using a Hofzinser cut,
which looks a little like that.
So those are your two cards--
the jack of hearts and
the king of hearts.
All right.
Everyone chose red cards today.
But you didn't.
I can see on your--
AUDIENCE: Eight of spades.
DAVID KWONG: Eight of spades?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: Eight of spades.
How many other cards?
Do you have a card?
One more?
OK.
Eight of spades.
Let's see if I get that.
Gosh.
Where is that?
I lost it.
Sometimes, I can get
one card to just pop up
like this off the
top of the pack.
That's the nine of hearts.
That's not it.
Sorry.
It's not my day.
OK.
Eight of spades.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, that is the eight of spades.
All right.
Yeah.
That's good.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, now he's getting good.
All right.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, what did you have, sir?
AUDIENCE: Nine of clubs.
DAVID KWONG: Nine of clubs.
The nine of clubs.
In the early 1900s,
Dr. Elliot of Boston
came up with something
called a back palm of a card.
I'm gonna show you what a
back palm is, Dr. Elliott's
back palm.
So I'm going to take
the ace of clubs.
And I will demonstrate
a back palm.
I'll do it over here
so everybody can see.
It looks a little like this.
I take that ace of clubs.
And I just wave my hand until
the card vanishes and then
reappears as the nine of clubs.
So that was good.
And then for the last card.
What did you have?
AUDIENCE: Five of clubs.
DAVID KWONG: Five of clubs.
So the last card,
the five of clubs.
Something a little more
acrobatic with the cards here.
I will attempt to do a
one-handed swivel cut,
get one card to fly out
of the middle of the deck,
rotate through the air
about 10 and 1/2 times.
I'm going to catch it
here in my right hand.
So here we go for
the five of clubs,
the top pivots to the bottom,
one card out of the middle.
And just like that, that
should be in the five of clubs.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
All right.
Thank you.
So let's see.
I need to introduce
another element here.
This is a kiwi that I
brought up from Los Angeles.
Can I give this to
you to just inspect?
Inspect the furry fruit.
No, don't eat it.
Don't break it.
That's a magical piece of fruit.
That needs to stay intact.
The other thing I'll need
is a single dollar bill
from someone.
Can people fish out their--
give the magician your money.
Do people have their--
you have dollar bills
[INAUDIBLE] to people?
Who's got one?
AUDIENCE: Right here.
DAVID KWONG: You've got one?
OK.
Thank you.
No, I'm gonna look at three.
All right.
Look how much money I got.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Yeah.
I'm going to give
this back to you, sir.
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: Alex.
DAVID KWONG: Alex?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: Would you
write your name right
over George Washington, please?
Now this is a federal offense.
But we're going to
keep this to face them.
I'm gonna give this back to you.
And then flip it
over to the backside.
Just flip it over.
And draw your favorite
marsupial on the back
of that bill for me, please.
Just quick.
You know, real quick.
Oh, a kangaroo.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID KWONG: Is it the best?
All right.
AUDIENCE: Oh, that's good.
DAVID KWONG: Let's
see how you did.
Let's see how you did.
Ooh.
Oh, there's a little
baby inside him!
That's funny.
OK.
So this is Alex's
favorite marsupial.
OK, great.
And we have an
Alex on the front.
OK.
I do this in every show.
This is actually the
first trick I ever learned
when I was a little kid.
So I do it in every
talk and every show.
And it involves folding
the bill down a few times.
And I would practice this
in front of the mirror
when I was a 7-year-old kid,
trying not to flash anything.
And that's not what you think.
Flashing is when you
expose part of the trick.
So you have to check your
angles in front of the mirrors.
And if I've done
this right, Alex,
your bill starts to look
a little bit different.
You can see it's
now a different hue.
In fact, the entire
denomination is--
you have 100 Russian rubles.
There we go.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
You probably lost about 20--
no, no.
You made $0.25 on
that transaction.
OK.
I'm going to try another thing
with a pack of playing cards
here.
Who can I pick on?
You guys are such a
democratic company.
Maybe you should all vote.
Submit your votes to--
OK.
I just looked at him--
Thomas.
I'm not a mind reader.
I can see your name tag.
[LAUGHTER]
Thomas, why don't
you join me on stage?
Everyone give Thomas a round
of applause for helping me.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
OK.
So Thomas, Come forward here
so everybody can see you.
You saw the playing
cards before.
I just want you to know
they're all different.
You have such a
grin on your face.
I love it.
Choose any card you like.
Take out a card.
That one or that one?
That one.
OK.
Show everybody else.
Don't show it to me.
All right.
Good.
Keep it against your chest.
So I can't see what it is.
And I'm going to spread
these cards out here.
And I want you to have
absolutely free choice,
except maybe not on
the top or the bottom
because that's too easy for me.
Go ahead and insert
that card anywhere else
you like in the deck.
OK.
Good?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: OK.
And then square up the
cards nice and slow.
Square up the cards so I can't
see exactly where you put it.
Cool?
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
DAVID KWONG: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So where do you think it is?
Where do you think it is?
Do you know the card is?
Voldemort?
Hi.
Do you want to?
OK.
I was all ready to do
something with that dog.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So here we are.
Voldemort the dog
interrupts a magic show.
That's amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
He who shall not be named.
So you can't really
call your dog.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
All right.
Thomas, you picked
a playing card.
You put it back
anywhere you wanted.
I'm going to snap my fingers.
And just like this, I'm
going to get it to come up
to the top like that.
And I can tell by
your lack of reaction
that that is not your card.
That is not your card.
OK.
So what I'm going to do instead
is eliminate this card entirely
from the equation by tearing
it into quarters like this.
OK.
And give me your
hand, if you would.
I'm going to give you--
kinda make a fist.
Turn it over.
Hold it just like that.
Now tell me for the first
time, what was the actual card
that you chose?
Not the jack, but
the actual card.
AUDIENCE: Two of hearts.
DAVID KWONG: Two of hearts.
And did you put it in
the top, middle, bottom?
Do you remember about?
AUDIENCE: The top-ish.
DAVID KWONG: Top-ish.
Top-ish.
So it's sort of up here.
OK.
Yeah, all right,
hasn't gone anywhere.
So what I'm going to try to
do is get the two of hearts
and the jack of diamonds
to change places
without you opening your hand.
Is that cool?
All right.
So let's try this.
OK.
Keep it nice and tight.
Go down a little bit.
Perfect.
I'm gonna take
that two of hearts.
And I'm going to touch
the back of your hand.
I'm going to come underneath,
and they should just
change places like that.
Because now I have
the jack of diamonds.
So if I have the
jack of diamonds,
what do you have in
your hand there, Thomas?
Take a look.
Hold up those pieces.
Show everybody what you got.
Is that the two of hearts?
That is the two of hearts.
Everyone give Thomas a round
of applause for helping me.
Thank you.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Don't go anywhere yet.
Give me your hand.
Make a fist.
Turn it over.
We're going to rewind the
clock about 30 seconds.
We're going to go back in time.
So you feel the pieces, right?
Let everybody know
they're in there.
Good.
OK.
And you go back in time
and give it a good squeeze.
And if you've truly gone
back in time, what have you
done to those pieces, Thomas?
Open your hand.
You have reconstituted the card.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Did I pick the right
guy or what for this?
[LAUGHTER]
All right, now everyone give
Thomas a big round of applause.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Who's is holding
the magic fruit?
AUDIENCE: That would be me.
DAVID KWONG: You still got it?
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: Monet.
DAVID KWONG: Monet?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: Would
you help me on stage?
Is that OK?
You're not like deathly
afraid of anything are you?
All right, everyone give
Monet a round of applause
for helping me on stage.
I have a knife here.
Inspect that.
Make sure there's
nothing weird about it.
No.
Please, take your time.
Make sure there's no
flaps or hinges or--
OK.
We're good.
We're good, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: OK.
I'm going to slice
into this fruit.
Oh, it sprays.
And you're gonna do
the difficult part.
You're gonna break off
the top of that fruit.
What do you see buried in
the middle of that fruit?
What do you see?
AUDIENCE: Money.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah.
Take that.
Pull it out.
OK.
Let's see if there is a little--
go ahead.
Open it.
Yeah.
I'm hoping there's a
marsupial with a little baby
inside of it.
Yeah.
Is that your dollar bill?
Thank you for your health.
I'm going to give that to you.
I'm going to trade you
for my Russian rubles.
All right so I'm going to talk
a little bit about Scrabble.
Do people like Scrabble?
Are there Scrabble
fans in the house?
Is this the white
board that I can use?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID KWONG: OK.
This is great.
It's good to go.
And I think there's
a marker here.
And then with what do I
erase this Scrabble board?
I'll turn it over.
So you we have to Scrabble
fans in the house, people
who play Scrabble?
Yeah.
Words With Friends,
Bananagrams, got any grammers
in the house-- grammers?
I play a lot of Scrabble.
It's actually been an exciting
18 months for Scrabble.
Because all these new words have
come out into the dictionary.
You can now play selfie.
Selfie is allowed in
the game is Scrabble,
as is hashtag is good.
Frenemy is now allowed
in the game of Scrabble.
I'm going to give you
a definition of a word.
Tell me what the word is.
Because it's funny.
It's a close, non-sexual
relationship between two men.
AUDIENCE: Bromance.
DAVID KWONG: Bromance is
now allowed in Scrabble.
You can also play--
you know the kayak, like
the boat, the kayak?
You can now spell
that Q-A-J-A-Q.
I know it's ridiculous, right?
Like who would ever use a
blank on their second Q?
Like who would ever do that?
But I want to talk to you.
I'm gonna give you a little
bit of a Scrabble hack.
There's a way that you
can score a lot of points.
And that's called bingo-ing.
Who knows what a bingo is?
What is a bingo, sir?
AUDIENCE: Using
all your letters.
DAVID KWONG: Yes.
When you use all
seven of your letters,
you get a 50 point bonus.
And the professional
Scrabble players-- and yes,
they do exist--
they bingo like four
or five times a game.
Now, I'm going to teach
you how to hack this.
If you get the Z or the X or
the Q, these high point value
letters, you actually
want to get rid of them
right away with short X, Q,
Z words, like Q-I and Z-A,
which is ridiculous.
Pizza, and now changed the
game the Scrabble forever.
But anyway, you
get rid of those.
So you end up with
the best letters
that you can anagram with.
And those are T, I, S, A, N, E--
TISANE.
OK.
Those are the best six letters
you can get and Scrabble.
Because you can add almost
any seventh letter to this,
rearrange them, and bingo.
It does not work with a Q.
It does not work with a Y.
But it works for the
other 24 letters.
I'm gonna show you what I mean.
Can I have a letter
from you, please?
AUDIENCE: L.
DAVID KWONG: So L
plus T, I, S, A, N, E,
you can spell elastin,
which I think is a protein.
But you don't have to know
in Scrabble what it means.
[LAUGHTER] You just have
to know that it is a word.
Elastin.
Can I have a letter
from you, please?
AUDIENCE: T.
DAVID KWONG: T you can spell--
I'm blanking all of a sudden.
I think you can spell satinet.
Yeah, that will get
your 50 point bonus.
Can I have a letter
from you, please?
AUDIENCE: R.
DAVID KWONG: R is
the best the letter
you can get because you don't
just have the TISANE list.
But you create the
SATIRE list as well.
So you can spell stainer and
retains and retinas and antsier
and get your 50 point bonus.
So that's kind of how
you hack the bingo lists.
These are called bingo lists.
I'm going to try one
other thing for you all.
Let's try this.
OK.
Raceways.
Sabbaths.
And sickbays.
Now, I'm going to put in the
values for these letters.
These values never change.
Let's do this.
Let's go 1, 1, 3,
1, 4, 1, 4, and 1.
And 1, 1, 3, 3, 1, 1, 4, and 1.
And 1, 1, 3, 5, 3, 1, 4, and 1.
I play a lot of Scrabble.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to add these three
eight-letter words, which I've
basically now converted to
three eight-digit numbers
into a new eight-digit number.
So 1 plus 1 plus 1 is--
let's this nice and pretty.
1 plus 1 plus 1 is 3.
And 1 plus 1 plus 1 is 3.
Now, before I began this,
there were some puzzle pieces,
as I like to call them, in play.
There was a kiwi,
which Monet, you
managed to find
what inside of it?
AUDIENCE: A dollar.
DAVID KWONG: A dollar,
which came from Alex.
And Alex, you have your
dollar there drying off.
So take a look at the
side that you signed,
the George Washington side.
And you'll notice in the
lower left hand corner,
there's an eight-digit
serial number.
Does it start with a 3, 3?
AUDIENCE: It sure does.
DAVID KWONG: It sure does.
What's to the right of the 3?
AUDIENCE: Nine.
DAVID KWONG: Should
be a 9, right?
3 plus 3 plus 3 is 9.
What do we have to
the right of that?
AUDIENCE: 9.
DAVID KWONG: Should
be another one, right?
1 plus 3 plus 5 is 9.
What do we have to
the right of that?
AUDIENCE: 8.
DAVID KWONG: We have an 8.
4 plus 1 plus 3 is 8.
And what do we have after that?
AUDIENCE: 4.
DAVID KWONG: Should be a 4.
Because here's where it
gets interesting, folks.
4 plus 4 plus 4 is 12--
carry the 1, mind you.
You get a 4.
4 plus 2.
And then we should
have a 3 at the end.
And 33998423.
Does that match
your dollar bill?
You're damn right it
matches your dollar bill.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions?
Now I will take questions.
Five minutes?
OK.
Five minutes for questions
more about the book
and less about this would be--
I'm going to give
you the microphone.
AUDIENCE: So did you
have any formal training?
Or did you make all this up?
DAVID KWONG: Did I have
any formal training?
No.
I started as a
seven-year-old kid.
I started with magic sets.
I started reading books.
I learned from
books, which I think
is the best way to learn
magic because you can watch
everything now on YouTube.
And you end up mimicking the
performer and his style when
you watch it on video.
But when you have
books and you're
trying to figure out
how to hold your hand,
you end up learning
it better that way.
But the truth of
my career arc is
that I did not think it was a
profession until six years ago.
So I've been doing
it my whole life.
But I had a normal desk job.
It was working in Hollywood.
I was at DreamWorks Animation.
And then all of a sudden,
it just kind of took off.
The movie, "Now You
See Me" came along.
They needed somebody
who understood movies
and understood magic.
And I also figured
out at the same time--
the light bulb
turned on-- oh, I can
take my two passions,
puzzles and magic,
and cross-pollinate them
and make something new.
And I really am a big
proponent of cross-pollination.
You take something
you're an expert in
and you add it to
something else.
And you produce a new product.
Yes.
Do we need to pass
the microphone over?
AUDIENCE: So who went back
and dug up all the cards
that he didn't choose
from the backyard trick?
DAVID KWONG: Great question.
I have told you
2/3 of the trick.
And at the end of chapter three,
you find out yet another twist.
And the fun thing for me is
that my friend, Edgar Wright,
will be finding out
for the first time
next week when he gets
his hands on the book.
Yes, hi.
AUDIENCE: So what
is the best book
you would suggest
for a child trying
to get into magic tricks?
DAVID KWONG: I started with
"The Klutz Book of Magic."
I hope they're still making it.
It comes with a ring and a
little handkerchief and a--
I don't want to say--
it comes with a fake
body part that you
can attach to yourself.
That's all I'll say.
But that's a great
book to start with.
Also Bill Tarr's,
"Now You See It,
Now You Don't," is a
great starter book.
And then Mark Wilson's,
"Complete Course in Magic,"
has everything in it.
So yeah.
Usually six or seven
years old is a good time
to start with that stuff.
You can buy some self-working
tricks in a magic shop.
That's also a great
way to get started is
you buy the self-working
stuff that doesn't
take sleight of hand ability.
And that way your child gets
comfortable lying to people.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So how does writing
a book compare
to writing a crossword puzzle?
DAVID KWONG: Oh.
Writing a book was torture.
That's how it compares.
But I made it through.
It was a year of
very, very hard work.
A crossword puzzle,
for me, is different
because there's a couple
of things going on.
When I come up with
a crossword theme,
I'm trying to figure out
how to fool you first.
That's why I think there's
an intersection of magic
and puzzles.
Because a good puzzle
will misdirect the solver
for a little bit of
what's going on and then
allowing them to
finally figure it out.
But what I do think puzzles and
writing a book and magic tricks
all have in common
is it's storytelling.
And a good puzzle takes
you through that arc where
you introduce the
material, and then there
are twists and turns, and then
there's that climactic "aha"
moment.
And what is the "aha"
moment in a puzzle?
The "aha" moment is when you
figure out what is going on.
And the great guru of
puzzles, Will Schwartz,
says that in that
"aha" moment, there
is a simultaneous
thing that happens.
You feel smart for
having solved it.
And you also respect
the constructor
for having come up with it.
So that is what
happens in that moment.
And yeah, I enjoyed
the process very
much of building a magic trick,
of having a arc to the book.
AUDIENCE: So who is your
favorite magician of all time?
And also who is--
DAVID KWONG: My least
favorite magician of all time.
AUDIENCE: Least favorite
magician, favorite magician,
and the coolest person
you've ever performed for,
or the coolest group.
DAVID KWONG: OK.
My favorite magicians
have been going
strong for decades and decades.
And Penn and Teller are
my favorite magicians.
I think there's a similar
sensibility in conveying
that we don't have superpowers.
And I just love how
irreverent they are.
And they're so clever.
And they find twists and turns
to put on every magic trick.
The coolest person
I've done magic for--
well, it was a small party
in Hollywood for Kathleen
Kennedy's birthday.
And she's now runs Lucasfilm
and produces all the Star Wars
movies.
So there were maybe 15 chairs.
And it was Kathy and Steven
Spielberg and J.J. Abrams.
And to fool other magicians
is a great, great honor.
AUDIENCE: And your
least favorite magician?
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID KWONG: We'll
talk after the show.
[LAUGHTER]
You know what?
I actually am going
to go with that
and say that magic is a
difficult, difficult trade
because of one
fundamental reason.
There are no intellectual
property laws
that can protect a magic trick.
So like a joke in
comedy, or a dance move,
or a director's shot in
film, these are expressions.
So every magician,
like comedians,
we're kind of all frenemies,
if not straight up enemies.
And that's because people,
especially the old guard
versus the younger guard, feel
like they're being stolen from.
And there are-- as I've
broken it down in this book.
And another approach is
to break down magic tricks
into the finite number of
illusions that have been made.
We dress them up in new ways.
And the magic tricks evolve
because we put new costumes
and dressing on them.
So a lot of the old
guard feel stolen from.
A lot of your peers
feel stolen from.
And that's why it's a
very tough, small field.
Teller, actually,
of Penn and Teller
managed to make a great
gain a couple of years
ago in a lawsuit
against somebody that
had copied his trick
and was marketing it,
was selling it for money.
And he ended up
winning that case.
AUDIENCE: So I assumed,
since things break down
into small pieces, when
you watch other magicians,
you probably know what's
going on most of the time.
Have you ever been fooled?
DAVID KWONG: I have
been fooled, yes.
I do speak the language.
And for the most part,
I can watch a show
and know exactly
what's happening.
And I appreciate it
for its execution.
I can be fooled by
very good misdirection.
I'm a human being
like everybody else.
If somebody has a very
powerful misdirection,
I'll look where I'm
not supposed to look.
But then I'll immediately be
like, oh, I know what happened.
And I can piece
it back together.
And then there are
other times where
there's a brand new
technical innovation
or a new move that will
completely fool me.
And I'll call my
friends immediately
and be like, please, please,
tell me what happened.
Please tell me what happened.
And they may they
make me wait 24 hours.
We call it the 24-hour rule.
And then they'll tell me.
But we have a term for when you
get fooled by another magician.
And that's called
getting burned.
You get burned.
And that's because we
feel it right here.
AUDIENCE: Does it detract
from your enjoyment
of watching magic shows that
you do see right through them?
DAVID KWONG: You probably
can make the argument
that I don't have
the same enjoyment
that everybody else has.
But I watch it now
for different reason--
for execution and inspiration.
AUDIENCE: How do you
think the book is
going to affect your
relationships with your friends
and coworkers now
that you're exposing
how you would manipulate
them into agreeing with you?
DAVID KWONG: Haha.
I see.
I thought you were
going to ask me
how the magic community
is going to react to that,
which we can also discuss.
No, I think I'm going to be OK.
I think that these
principles, you
can put them to use
in the right way.
And usually, they
are in situations
that you're really in control
of and that you've planned for.
And this is not a handbook
on how to walk into a bar
and be able to pick up anybody.
So there was a book
called "The Game"
that came out that
was like that.
And I really wanted this to be
different, completely different
spirit that I wrote this in.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have ideas on how
the things you talked
about at the beginning,
like the illusion of choice
and how people pick a side
and they stick to it, can
be applied to politics
and the current
political environment
and what you would do about it?
Like if you were superhero
using your magician powers, what
are you going to do?
DAVID KWONG: Well, I
think you're right.
It's very hard to sway people
when they stick to their ideas.
And I don't want to
get too political.
But I think we can
probably all agree
that there is a master of
misdirection in the White House
right now.
Tommy Wonder, the
great Dutch magician,
said that misdirection is
giving people something
of greater interest to look at.
So like bad misdirection
would be you're doing a show
and then somebody drops a tray
full of metal pots and pans,
and everyone's like [INAUDIBLE].
But good misdirection is
something of greater interest
that they can pay attention to.
If I were to make a
bird appear, you're
all going to-- that's like
the end of the trick, right?
I've showed you an
empty handkerchief.
I make a bird appear.
You're not going to want to
ignore that because it's cool.
And it's the end of the trick.
But in that moment, I'm already
reaching for my next thing
and setting up my next trick.
And I think that he
who shall not be named
is a master at giving
us something else that
takes our attention that
we're interested in.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.